[Music]
in the rainforest one sharpshooter is in
search of its next target meet the
velvet worm a nearly blind creature with
an impressive weapon the worm is
sensitive to air currents caused by
movements and uses this to hunt The
Velvet worm moves so slowly that its
prey usually doesn't notice it
approaching the worms secret weapons are
two pistols that fire sticky ropes up to
a foot long
it's like silly string of death the
substance then paralyzes the prey with
fast-drying adhesive the worm also has a
knife in its jaw and uses it to slice
its prey open it then injects saliva
that liquefies the insides of any
unlucky victim
so to recap this creature that looks
like a scary alien monster and can feel
you through the air moves slowly like
it's in a horror film before projectile
spraying you with its sticky Super
Soaker of death rendering you powerless
to only watch as it then stabs you with
the knife it has hidden in its jaws like
a prison shank that it uses to rip you
apart before drinking your organs yeah
that thing is terrifying
[Music]